[Musique]
ils prennent possession du plateau du
théâtre de saint germain en laye les
cinq danseurs de la compagnie de danse
l'éventail répète chaque geste pour
s'approprier l'espace ils seront
accompagnés sur la scène par cinq
comédiens et 10 musiciens alors
qu'istres ensemble ils jouent le mariage
forcé une comédie ballet de molière et
lully
ce canard elle a 53 ans a décidé
d'épouser dorimène qu'on a probablement
17 donc on peut s'attendre à ce que de
rue mais ne soit pas contente et ben si
elle est ravie elle est ravie parce
qu'elle pense que ce canard et les
riches que comme ça lors elle ne sera
plus soumise à la tutelle de son père et
qu'elle pourra faire ce qu'elle voudra
comme elle voudra ce n'est pas vraiment
l'idée que se gagnent à raser du mariage
tel est pris qui croyait prendre celui
qui voulait forcer la jeune fille a
marriage se retrouve forcée d'épouser la
jeune fille
créé au xviie siècle le mariage forcé
est la première vraie collaboration
entre lully molière et beauchamp dans
cette version 2022 de nombreuses
adaptations des défaites là nous avons
proposé un décor des costumes qui n'ont
aucun rapport avec le xviie siècle en
tant que tel mais dont on espère qu'au
contraire ils ont reflété précisément
l'espèce de joie de fantaisie
d'irréalité de poésie de loufoquerie qui
est tout le sel du mariage forcé le
metteur en scène et la chorégraphe de la
comédie ballet travaillent étroitement
ensemble pour mettre en lien les parties
théâtrale et les parties dansées un
travail complexe je trouve ça vraiment
très difficile parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de contraintes d'espacé justement
avec un orchestre vivant c'est à la fois
passionnant et en même temps basse est
beaucoup plus risqué tirer le fil entre
ses 400 ans pour à la fois ne pas
dénaturer l'esprit le sens de ce qu'il
ya de ce qu'ont voulu faire molière et
lully et les beaux chants le maître à
danser à l'époque et que ça parle à des
gens maintenant de partager ça
voilà c'est une gageur la première du
mariage forcé aura lieu ce jeudi 17
février à 20h45 sur la scène du théâtre
alexandre dumas
[Musique]